[Music]
I think for those of us who have a
certain skepticism of military
intervention and focus on the last 15 or
20 years and really see that
notwithstanding the heroic efforts of
the members of our military and the
sacrifices they've made just how
difficult it is to achieve rather
abyssion objectives through the use of
force we have a tendency to focus
therefore on what we're against we're
against intervening in wars that do not
serve a clear compelling national
interest and have a clear and achievable
military objective but it's equally
important for us to think about what
type of engagement we are for and I
think that's why it is so important to
talk about trade to talk about cultural
engagement to talk about why the United
States is made stronger and better by
regular interactions with the rest of
the world when we hear President Trump
and others talk about America first it
raises a number of important questions
the first it is the first time this was
really used in the United States was in
the interwar period the 1930s which is
understandably rather fraught the the
result of that isolationism and and
separation from Affairs in Europe and
Asia is seen as one of the great
failings of u.s. foreign policy and so
not being aware of sort of the
historical baggage that comes with the
term America first is bad enough more
importantly I think in the in the modern
era in the 21st century it's simply
impossible and not wise for the United
States to think then it cannot be
engaged with the rest of the world there
probably was a time early in our history
where we were so focused on developing
our own internal affairs and sort of
building our markets here in the United
States that we could trade with others
but mostly be focused here at home I
don't think that's a realistic scenario
anymore and frankly I don't want to live
in the United States that's not actively
engaged with the rest of the world so
the real question is not so much America
first but what brand of American
engagement with the rest of the world do
we want how do we get there and I think
that in many ways the way that President
Trump talks about it it's going in the
wrong door
by throwing up trade barriers and
sending a message to those who might
wish to come to the United States
they're not welcome here those who are
here under dubious circumstances are
being you know shown there the door or
being escorted out of the country not
always so gently and I think it sends a
pretty chilling message that the United
States is not open for business I know
that's not necessarily his intention but
I think that the the notion that the
United States can exist and thrive
without being intricately connected with
the rest of the world is simply false
and dangerous privacy was created during
World War two and after World War two on
the basis of an open international
trading system somewhat distinct from
the trading system under the colonial
empires or even in the 1930s where trade
protectionism and sort of
beggar-thy-neighbor policy really drove
and deepened the economic crisis the
global economic crisis so the lessons
that came away from World War two were
that the United States would sponsor a
set of international institutions like
the World Bank the International
Monetary Fund that would serve as sort
of a stabilizing force it would also
serve work to liberalize trading regimes
and reduce tariff barriers through the
general agreement on tariffs and trade
which ultimately sort of evolved into
the World Trade Organization this was
what we mean by the liberal
international order as it exists today
is it is these international
institutions and these norms that
encourage countries to trade with one
another and discourage them from placing
artificial barriers to other countries
and businesses trading with them well
it's simply unbelievable that the United
States could exist independent of the
rest of the world where on earth would
we go and I think I would much rather
live in a United States that is
regularly trading with the rest of the
world that does engage and that is
welcoming of others visitors students
other businesses all of that sort of
thing and I think that's the part of the
conversation that we have
spent enough time talking about that
engagement with the rest of the world
does not have to come at the barrel of a
gun and in fact for most of American
history it didn't come at the barrel of
a gun for most of American history the
United States was an exemplar of the
type of system the type of liberal free
system that we wanted other countries to
emulate and that model served us well
for much of our history and I think it
would serve us well in the modern era as
well
[Music]